one of the major benefits of the ps5 and
xbox series consoles is hdmi 2.1
but what exactly are the benefits of
hdmi 2.1
and is it worth upgrading your tv for
the next-gen hardware
in short hdmi 2.1 is the latest version
of hdmi that distinguishes itself by
being capable of transmitting an
impressive bandwidth of 48 gigabits per
second in the cable
this is a huge improvement from the
previous 2.0 cables which carry 18
gigabits per second
bandwidth determines the max amount of
data the signal and the cable can send
the higher the resolution and the frame
rate the more data is needed
if you're playing a ps4 pro or xbox one
x in 4k
you've been using a 2.0 cable which can
support up to 4k
resolution at 60 frames a second with
static hdr
hdmi 2.1 is capable of 4k at 120
fps or 8k at 60fps
it also supports dynamic hdr lighting on
a frame by frame
basis as well as a color gamma of bt
2020
and 16 bit per color this means it's
capable of supporting tvs that have a
wide color gamut
making your image look even nicer hdmi
2.1 includes
auto low latency mode or allm
this will tell your tv that you're
playing a video game and instantly
switch it over to its low latency game
mode
setting hdmi 2.1 also has a vrr
a built-in variable refresh rate that
keeps your display's refresh rate in
tune with the supported device's frame
rate
so everything is smooth the new consoles
will support
vrr between 30 and 120 so what does this
all mean for your fancy new console
well both the ps5 and xbox series x use
hdmi 2.1 to enable games to run up to 4k
at 120 frames per second if you're
buying an xbox series s the console also
has an hdmi 2.1 port but it instead
targets a resolution of 1440p at 120fps
which hdmi 2.0 can already support
but using 2.1 on the series s will still
give you the benefits of dynamic hdr
as well as improved color and
subsampling the other benefit of hdmi
2.1
is 8k support both the ps5 and xbox
series x are capable of outputting 8k
but very few games will run in 8k for
the foreseeable future
meaning there isn't much of a reason to
worry about it for gaming
the big selling point of hdmi 2.1 right
now is the improved color
and 4k at 120 fps high frame rates like
120fps have typically been the domain of
pc gamers but now console gamers can
enjoy it too
a few examples of games that support 120
fps include devil may cry 5 special
edition and
dirt 5 as well as the multiplayer modes
in call of duty black ops cold war
and halo infinite a few previous gen
games will also be getting 120 fps
updates for the new consoles such as
gears 5
orion the will of the wisps and rainbow
six siege
as many pc gamers can attest frame rates
above 60 fps do lead to a smoother
gameplay experience and provide a
competitive edge in multiplayer
if you're interested in having games run
the best they can or want every
advantage and call of duty you can get
hdmi 2.1 is for you but what do you need
to actually get
hdmi 2.1 running for starters you'll
need a 2.1
cable presumably the ps5 and series x
will come with one
in the box but on the off chance they
don't and you need to buy one
look for the phrases ultra high speed
hdmi 2.1
and 48 gigabits per second always check
the specs on the product page
and look at reviews to make sure the
cable isn't cheaply made
the major thing you need to worry about
when it comes to your money though is
having a tv that supports hdmi 2.1
and 4k at 120 fps being a newer
technology you're only going to find
this in the latest models
and even then not all of them will
support it so make sure to check the
specs on the product page as well as
reviews
if you're planning on owning both
next-gen consoles or want to plug in
your pc as well
it's worth noting that most tvs with 2.1
only have it in
one hdmi port meaning you'll need to
swap around system cables
the only tv we're aware of at this
moment that has hdmi 2.1
in all of its ports is the new lg oled
cx series
it also supports g-sync and freesync
which is great for variable refresh
rates in pc gaming
and is in my personal opinion the best
high-end gaming tv on the market
that isn't ridiculously priced in fact
if this video does have you interested
in buying a tv we have an article over
on gamespot.com rounding up the best 4k
tvs for next gen
including the lg cx i just mentioned the
link is in the description below
but all of that said if hdmi 2.1 doesn't
sound like something you have to have
you can always wait until the technology
becomes more widespread and less
expensive
the reality is most games that aren't
multiplayer experiences
aren't going to support 120 fps for a
while and the ones that do might not
even be at 4k
resolution opting instead for 1440p or
even
1080p heck we'll probably still be
getting big budget graphical showcases
that shoot for 4k
30fps the improvements to color dynamic
hdr
and the variable refresh rate offered
with hdmi 2.1
are still major advancements that more
next-gen games will take advantage of
but how worthwhile these improvements
are is all dependent on how you feel
about your current tv
if you just upgraded your tv recently
and don't care about 120 fps
i wouldn't worry about hdmi 2.1 but if
you've been waiting to get a whole new
setup for the next gen then definitely
consider hdmi 2.1 when looking at new
tvs
if for nothing else then the give
yourself more options and how you play
your games
[Music]
you